A BOOST FROM THEIR HOME FANS. F.
GETS TO THE NET THE SPEED THROU
NEUTRAL ZO
ONE, CROSS CREASE IT.
THE K
[ ♪ ]
>> Craig: HERE'S A LOOK AT THAT
NOW IT IS CODY CECI, A CHANCE TO
BYRAM BACK.
HE'S HALFWAY FROM BEING DOWN AND
UP AND GOES RIGHT UNDERNEATH HIS
ARMS, SL
GET YOUR CONFIDENCE GOING AND
.
IT'S AN OFFENSIVE ZONE FACE OFF.
>> Chris: AND THEY WANT IT.
GET THE MATCH-UP GAME.
YOU GET A LITTLE BIT OF A TOUGH.
ERIC JOHNSON, THE LONGEST
JOHNSON ABLE TO WORK THAT AHEAD.
AFTER A COUPLE OF CHANCES LINE
DUNCAN KEITH.TURNS.
O'CONNOR WORKS IT PAST
THE AVALANCHE'SLEAD.
>> CraAKAR NUGE CORNER.
STURM, A CHANCE. ON
SIDE.
JUST AT THE LAST SECON BARRIE.
AND NOW THEY WILL GET INTO THEIR
>> Craig: THIS SAVE IS POSSIBLE
AND COMPHER OUT OF THE BOX.
BOUCHARD GOT TO GET IT BACK IN A
HURRY AND COMPHER AND OUT.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THE BOARDS.
GETS AWA
YOU KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO NOT JUST .
DO IT OFFENSIVELY BUT